good morning again uh so nice for me to
have you all here uh listening to me
talking about grpc what it is and why
you should maybe have a look at it
yeah so who am I I'm from Romania I'm an
independent consultant
um I organize a.net user group I
teach.net and I blog from time to time
not as I often as often as I would like
to
but I've been busy doing this I said
while I'm on maternity leave I will do
something important to my career and I
did that so A book aimed at uh beginners
talking about all kind of things around
web and web API
so if you know someone that might
benefit from reading that
cool so I'm gonna start with the story
because I like stories and since I
started developing with dotnet
web forms
does that sound familiar
yeah I'm sure it sounds familiar yeah so
uh
back in the days we had monoliths with
web forms because that's how the
framework used to work
but with the monoliths that we have back
then
everything was very easy at least for me
as a junior developer and I will have to
ask you who here enjoyed or enjoys why
not working with monoliths
I I'll be the first one saying that
admitting it why well because it is it
it gives us an easy life as developers
everything gets in the same code base
everything is in there you do not have
to worry that you will break something
if you change something you don't have
to orchestrate things
um like yeah Services other services
so on the deal with the monolith is that
it's hard to scale in specific scenario
you can scale it but will cost a lot for
components of the system that well maybe
are not used that much so the scaling
for that is just waste of money
okay so we started from this kind of
architectures where everything was
self-contained we had web forms we had
MVC that pretty much did the same thing
yeah it tried The Logical separation of
the code but in the end everything was
on the server side the HTML was
outputted from the from the server side
and so on and then we realized that the
next big thing is to split the front end
and the back end into two separate
things so then we started to adopt the
next big thing back then like rest apis
yeah so I'm gonna ask another thing who
here develops rest apis
so who here really develops the rest API
respecting all the constraints that the
rest should have
mm-hmm yeah exactly so I'll be the oh I
see one hand here good for you
okay
that's awesome yeah but let's admit it
most of us did the same thing we're
basically having not rest API we call
them restful apis but we have HTTP apis
that return Json yeah that's what we
have so since we have that and we all
know that the future is distributed well
then we started to kind of have things
like this
one front end that consumes a lot of
back-ends then another architecture kind
of appeared we have back-ends for front
ends and things like that and then we
started to have a microservice
architectures yeah having small things
that serve Json to be consumed by a
consumer that usually is a client app or
why not is another server because that's
basically what grpc were going to be
yeah so the main purpose of grpc would
be to be consumed by another server
in the role of a consumer
yes and then there might be systems that
have this kind of
polyglot
infrastructure architecture so we might
have like a net consuming a goal service
and stuff like that
yeah so
we might have that have you ever seen it
in real life like dotnet that app
consuming something from java
you've seen it yeah but you see there
are not a lot of us that have seen this
this exotic thing uh in real life yeah
because we all know that we all have
rest for everything and rest or HTTP
apis supposedly uh talk in Json which is
common for any kind of
um language framework that we might need
an encounter so
I might ask you okay so why are you here
why am I here talking about grpc because
we all have rest right
so what's wrong with it why shouldn't we
use rest for everything yeah if you have
a messaging our sector that you're using
buses queues and stuff like that yeah
that's another level but when you start
with microservices the first thing that
you do is to create an HTTP client
get data from one side to another
because that's the normal step to do and
then once you evolve your architecture
then you might actually use the message
broker yeah so there's nothing wrong
with rest but we kind of use it
everywhere yeah and because we use it
everywhere we might have like not so
Performance Services or we might as well
have a look at other technologies that
might bring an extra uh benefit for us
yeah and we all know that there are
other Technologies out there that can
maybe I know fit our solution without
business requirements and so on so here
we go introducing a remote procedure
call
uh well a remote procedure call it's not
a thing that's new it has been around
since I don't know 70s or something like
that
yeah the whole purpose of an RPC system
or RPC
concept is to make the system look and
behave like their a monolith yeah so you
have a distributed system and using a
remote procedure calls you might get the
feeling that you have the whole uh thing
in one place
yeah so let's have a look at some code
yeah so what we have here is an order we
call a create order we have a payment
status that we want uh to process the
payment for and if that payment is
successful yeah well we might arrange
the shipping for it yeah I named it
maybe not so uh
so good but if we look at this code
there's nothing telling us that there
might be a network involved whenever we
call the method yeah it's just call a
method approach we're calling the
process payment for the specific order
we arranged the shipping for this
specific order so it's just method calls
it's not the new HTTP client it's not
visible that we're behind the scenes or
doing HTTP requests right so this is
what RPC has a concept does
it has a network that it becomes hidden
once we uh we use it
so RPC would make the code look local
right
we process the payments it looks like
it's in the same system like it's in
there
yeah so it has this look at feel of
color method take their instantiate
something called the method and so on
yeah because the the main goal of an RPC
is to have a distributed system behave
behave like a monolith okay and since
it's doing that the communication
through the network it's transparent
it's not like it's
yeah you look through it you're not
seeing that is there
so here we are introducing grpc
so grpc starting to in 2001 so it's not
that new anymore it's new in our.net
ecosystem
uh it all was open source like many
other projects that we currently use and
well fast forwarding a few years we got
it in.net in 2019.
since then
um I will tell you that a lot of the
tooling that you is used for grpc
improved
so now things are way stable so now I
can use the thing in production because
also the tooling helps me
but back then things weren't that stable
so there was to me at least there was
nothing that would have made me sad okay
I'm gonna use this tomorrow in a
production environment yeah but nowadays
if you ask me the same thing I would say
yes I'm using this and I'm gonna use
this for specific scenarios
what is grpc so grpc is called contract
based and it means that we will have no
more right click add reference package
so on uh it the only thing that will be
common between all our project using
grpc will be a file yeah how would you
distribute that file well it's up to you
I'm going to talk about it by the end
it uses HTTP to by default it was
especially made for this which will make
it faster and now we're going to say
okay but I can also use HTTP 2 with a
web API right yeah well
you can use HTTP 2 with a web API but it
won't use the the protocol at its
fullest
another thing that is very nice about
grpc is that it has a different
serialization called protobuf which will
give you a smaller payload I did a few
tests and it gave me for the same data
about 50 50
smaller payload which is big I mean
you're gonna reduce your
data transfer over the network with 50
which is awesome and if you top that
with compression it becomes even better
and another thing is that is available
in many languages
it does code generation out of the box
it will generate client for you and the
code that you're specifying there and
it's all done by the the compiler the
protoc compiler
okay so where does the grpc concept fits
in so how do we introduce in in our
system so with ABI we had the client we
had the server but now in between those
we will have something that is common
and known by by both parties we will
have this protophile which is a file
with a special syntax so basically the
the thing that is common it will be in
between you'll have a file that is known
both to the consumer and both of the
server yeah that's it so if with web API
for example I know I've seen it in the
teams that I've worked with they created
nugget packages to distribute HTTP
clients
strongly typed ones they have retrial
policy already involved in there but the
thing with that it was that the library
that's supposed to be just the client to
be sent and used in every um
microservice
tended to I don't know to reinhairit
business logic
which wasn't that nice
yeah so
since you do not have the possibility of
I don't know Distributing nugget
packages and you have only this file
you're not prone to errors you won't
have spaghetti code in your in your
system
so how the protophile looks like
it's fairly strange
it's a fairly different terminology but
in the end this file will be generated
and it will be it will output c-sharp
code yeah so it will output classes the
first thing that you have to do is to
specify the syntax version for the
protocol buffers then you need to
specify if you want the namespace under
which the class will be generated
and then you will need to specify what
are you exposing what are your
operations what are the the types that
you want to Define in here so you do
that by simply specifying the service
keyword the name of the service and
you're going to say hey I have an RPC
method because this is what we expose
name compute Fibonacci of type requested
number that Returns the Fibonacci result
uh the thing here is that you cannot
have operation that have no uh
parameters you would have to have
something even though if that something
is empty yeah so you will Define a type
that has no properties inside it
or use the the things that are already
uh created by Google a message as you'll
see here the requested number is the
name and then inside it you have like a
field
yeah but that is not a field it will
become a property once the protocol
compiler will run
and the requested number will become a
c-sharp class that you will be able to
use
yeah the thing is in 32 number equals
one that is not an assignment
that is uh the order in the binary
string
yeah so once you add many properties you
will add them and you will equal the
number and the word that you want to
have it in the binary string
yeah so this is how it looks like it we
will have a look at some code right away
okay so um
now you have to know another syntax now
you have to Define files new files and
these files are the ones that are
getting distributed to your system yeah
so how you distribute them because you
will have no more right click add
reference or install nugget package
well some people are having separate
repositories for it
and some people are just pointing
um I'm just referencing these files from
a specific location on the disk on the
network or somewhere on the web
okay we're gonna see that in action uh
soon enough
one of the powers of grpc is that is
used as the protocol behind the scenes
and it provides something that it's
called grpc types or modes
which are four of them
one of them is stream is unary that
makes client server request response
pattern that we know yeah from the web
API and the second the next three ones
can be named as streaming types because
those will do streaming
first one will be the service streaming
then client streaming and then a
combination of these two the thing is
whenever streaming happens it happens on
one TCP connection
yeah so what will happen is that a
consumer usually still a server
will issue requests that request will be
uh processed and you'll send the
response back yeah how do you define
such method in your service protofile
well easy you say that it's a RPC you
give it a name you give it an input and
you also give a return type that you
also need to Define
the deal is the consumer needs to
initiate the communication yeah so it
the server cannot say hey I'm going to
send you messages no it doesn't work
like that
server streaming is a client initiating
opening a communication Channel
the server receiving uh that request and
then it will answer one answer with
several things over the same connection
so this is streaming it will stream
bytes of data so it's not signalr it
cannot like broadcast to different
clients but the clients can open a
communication Channel and it will reuse
the same connection
server streaming
can be written just by using by addict
the stream keyword near to the the part
that you wanted if you want to respond
with a stream of outputs then you add
the stream stream keyword to the part
that you want it to be streamed
client streaming Works in a similar
manner but this time the clients sends
several pieces of data over the same
connection and the server will respond
with only one thing yeah
so uh how do you write that by adding
the stream keyword to the part that will
be streamed okay think about scenarios
where we need to upload big uh
data like I don't know uploading a movie
uh a recording or something like that we
can chunk the big data and several
pieces and we can stream it to the
server that would be a good scenario or
another thing maybe upload data from
different sensors in the iot scenarios
think about it you're opening a
connection towards the server to send
something and you send something very
often
with RPC or grpc you might as well just
open a connection and whenever you have
something to send you will send over the
same connection so it won't be like new
connection new connection new connection
every time it will be just one
connection and whenever you have
something to say send you'll reuse the
the same connection
bi-directional it works combining the
two um
parts
and how do we write that just by adding
the same keyword to the input and to the
output that's it
okay so uh
let's demo some things
I think I'm gonna just
make sure that everyone sees what I have
here
okay
gonna try to zoom it in
at the default project with Visual
Studio at least it has the things that
we already know it has the programs yes
it has an app settings but it will have
no no controllers folder like web API
does it will have a produce folder and a
Services yeah so let's have a look here
in the products for uh folder you add
your protocol buffer files yeah so I
hope this is visible
far back
that's the best I can do
okay so I have a service named greeter
with four methods
one of them is unary server streaming
you'll see that it has
only an input but it returns a stream of
responses so it's going to be once again
and several things out this is gonna how
it's gonna work on the client stream
it's the other way around it has a lot
of inputs and it will return
only one thing out
and in the bi-directional part it will
be many ins many outs yeah so depending
on uh
what we have the message is that are
defined I call them requests I call them
I gave them like a single property
because the purpose was to show you how
it really works not to make complicated
things
once you define these messages you can
Define like your types your
correspondent
um from your c-sharp classes in here you
can import them just like you would do
for with CSS files yeah you import one
here there one thing there and you're
gonna work in the end you can also
Define like nested types if that's the
case so maybe the request will have
another property that is of type message
and so on and so forth
what happens is whenever you build this
in this thing something will be
generated for you
you'll find that generated file under
here in the debug object debug net
version that you have you'll see that
there will be like two separate classes
generated on build so what Visual Studio
does is to run a proto-c CLI command and
obtain this so you can also do it by
hand if you want without using visual
studio
okay and this classes have a funky
looking uh
yeah we do not
I advise you not to modify this because
otherwise the results
won't be predictable client your PC here
the same this is the generated
is you see the classes are generated as
being partial it they have the name that
you generated you have the service the
namespace in there
and stuff like that okay so what do we
do with this generated code because okay
we obtained that but we also need to
give it an implementation because it's
not only necessary okay I'm gonna do the
definition here who you work with soap
services having that wizal file yeah
I could say that I might be opinionated
but this protocol might be the version
the modern version of The Whistle yes
because if we look at that
we see what we're exposing yeah there
will be a method called say hello that
will receive this as an input and we'll
output that as an output
yeah so uh it's our job to take the
generated code and to give an actual
implementation to be used further yeah
so what we're going to do we will create
a service
and then once we create the service we
will have to register it
and uh
startup to be bundled yeah and when we
do that we might go ahead and say hey I
needed to extend greater greater base
greater base is automatically generated
is the funky looking code that we've
seen
yeah and in there if we write hey public
override
something
it will give us what we have to be
generated yeah in here I already wrote
the code for every method but if I
haven't
done that I would be prompted hey you
can overwrite the say hello yeah so the
say hello method it will be an override
from the base that is generated with
protossif compiler uh it hasn't
I don't know what happens it has a
request a request
um as a parameter and it has a second
parameter that we cannot get rid of
cold server called context
okay what's happening
my laptop is acting out
which is not cool at all
okay and the server call context it's
something that relates to the grpc
request itself
you can obtain from there for example
the actual HTTP context that we all know
from web API or MVC we can call the
context parameter get HTTP context and
we will get everything in there we can
access the headers we can access
everything that's HTTP related and we
all know
and we can even access the current users
if we have authentication in place yeah
or if we have client certificates and
stuff like that
okay so now that we have the server and
by the way you're going to have access
to this code at the end so no uh no need
to take pictures or something like that
okay what I'm gonna show you is I have a
few console apps running
one of them will be the server that I
just show you
um running let me clear this out
so I'm going to dot net
sorry run no build
and what's gonna happen is that it's
gonna listen on this port so now once my
grpc server is up I can do grpc request
to it and how will I do that just by
using other console apps
what I have in here is a unary console
application
so nothing fancy but I want you to see
that under the dependencies
I have no dependency to my server so
basically it doesn't know which the
server where is the server what is the
server code and stuff like that it
doesn't know yeah the only thing that
this specific project knows is where is
my protocol protocol file basically yeah
so if I right click and say when I did
the project
I'm gonna see a thing here
say hey I'm going to include from the
server project products folder a file
name grid and here I'm going to behave
like I am oh wow
exactly go
like I'm a client so I'm going to be a
client for
um for for a server another thing that
we could do in here which is fairly new
in visual studio and it helps a lot is
to Simply say right click
add
and you'll say add service reference
and from here you're going to see this
prompt that is going to ask you hey what
do you want to add an open API a WCF or
a grpc and if you click grpc it's going
to prompt you to browse and find the
file that you want to be visible to this
specific project
and if you click browse
um you're gonna go to the server part
you're going to see the protocol file
select the grid Proto
and in here you can select what kind
what code you wanted to have client
server content server or messages only
so only the types that you define the
request or the response kind
you're gonna click finish
and you'll see it's gonna install or not
a few projects that's an older version
uh but in the end it will make the
classes generated
for you discoverable in this project so
you can either do that and it will work
if you have a new project or you can
either go and just edit this and add by
hand the location of the file and the
fact that this is a client
on the server side I'm going to show you
the difference for this
on the server side if you edit the
project file
you'll notice that it has pretty much
the same thing
yeah so it points to the grid protophile
and it says that this in here behaves
like a server so that's what it makes a
specific project be the client so the
consumer of a service or the service
itself yeah
and every time you need to uh you want
and need to add another protocol file
you need to make sure that you include
it in here to be discoverable
um
and also that you register the service
okay
things code related
since I show you how you can add
and reference a protocol file I can also
show you how you can consume a specific
service so what's going to happen using
this grpcnet client this is the Nugget
package that you will need to install in
order to make something work with grpc
to consume grpc Services you can say hey
I need for this specific address
our server will run under this port
I needed to create the channel so it's a
communication Channel yeah so once you
create that and pass options to it you
can also send
for example that um
you can configure retry policies in
there out of the box hedging policies
you can pass here there are like
authentication things like token bearers
stuff like that so that's a HTTP level
below you'll see that we are creating
clients that are pretty much similar to
what we use in web API clients you'll
create a client you'll instantiate the
client pass the address stuff like that
and then just call methods
that's what happens here so greater
greater client
it is part of those funky looking
classes generated from our protophile
and we'll simply pass the channel in it
and then we need to create our request
passive value and just
call the
the user client and call the method that
we we want so we're going to call him
here say hello passing in the request
okay so you see here the client has what
we defined the protofile bi-directional
client stream uh server stream and so on
yeah so uh the client itself used from
another app want to know if you
implemented the actual Logic for the
specific method
but once you defined it in here it will
be visible and discoverable but it will
draw exceptions that hey yeah it's not
implemented
yeah so it's up to you to provide the
actual logic in your service
getting back to our demo
service listening
and on the right side I'm gonna have
another client app that will do will run
our console consumer
so I'm going to dotnet run
yeah so what we see here is that is
sending a message
and it gets back a response with Oslo
value which is the value that we sent
and it also adds another thing uh the
the server that it runs because I'm
always I'm gonna show you the the client
load balancing
okay so let's see what happened on the
server side because that's very
important I'm gonna try and
do this on the server side
we will see that these are HTTP too yeah
so that's the port that it runs on it is
a post request
so every time you're using uh you're
making a grpc call it will be an actual
post request so you cannot have like get
requests put updates batch delete and
some stuff like that
which comes with a drawback having posts
means you'll have no caching
yeah so the only thing that you'll
benefit from is the small payload the
serialization and pretty much that's it
and you'll see that it calls the end
point
um greater grid say hello this is the
end point it's not an actual endpoint
it's an operation over the network and
it has the application grpc
mime type in here yeah so that will
happen every uh single time you do call
grpc operation
okay so that's what happens on the
server side
you'll see here with that I turned in um
the trace logging option and it it does
and writes every single step that it uh
so it's ending the message it serialized
the server response it has this amount
of size and then it compresses the
message with the gzip and coding
and then it actually sends the message
and then it finished executing the
endpoint and stuff like that so you can
get all these small steps just by
turning the logging on on Trace
on this next part
since we're having
urinary we will have to have a look at
the client string for example
the client streaming is super easy
so basically you're calling the method
and the simple logic that I could add in
here is just to have a for Loop that
will write to the request stream
every for every eye that I send a new
request type and then I'm going to wait
uh for the requesting to be complete and
well just I I'm going to write in the
console let's see that in action
okay so units done the server is still
listening
and on the client stream
I'm gonna do the same
dot net run
hoping this won't
and what I want you to see on the left
side on the server part that it moves
yeah it receives things from the client
and it will keep receiving things until
our I gets to the maximum value
fingers crossed we're going to wait a
bit
okay
and it stopped it it said that okay it's
gzipped the thing received the message
reading the message no message to return
stuff like that
and in here uh this number is the last
value the server receives so it's one
single response to the client yeah in
here we sent many many many many many
many messages from the client
the server will still be listening and
on the right hand side we're going to
try the server side
server streaming server streaming means
that once the client issues the request
it will receive a lot of things back so
I'm going to dotnet run
you see the server sends things
and the client sees those things
and write them into console
that's is the same scenario with an I
that goes
back and
I hope I didn't add too many too many
eyes in there
okay stop it now where are we gonna stop
it
I know it stops itself okay so uh this
is what the server sent back so this is
the last value and there's another thing
that we're gonna talk about
um
in a few minutes
okay let's see how the
client code looks like for this
server streaming
it uses the same approach
it opens the channel yeah it passes in
the address where it can find the server
and then it simply calls the server
stream with a new request yeah
and for which response received it will
write the response in the console yeah
so this is a simple code just awaiting
and reading from the response stream yes
on one part it's writing to the response
stream and this is reading for the from
the response stream
okay
let's see also on the server side how
the service looks like so server stream
yeah
writes a message and writes in the
response to to push things to the client
yeah
um you'll see here that you have the
request so the type that you get in and
then you have a server stream uh
I server stream writer which means that
you need to use that to write just like
you would use it with a memory stream
and then the server called context that
you cannot get rid of it it will be
there the only thing that will be funny
about it the server called context it's
when you're going to implement like unit
test over grpc you will have to to pass
that also as a parameter
okay and uh bi-directional one
um
I'm gonna demo soon enough so you have
an eye stream stream reader you have to
read from the the consumer and you'll
have to write back
and you'll have the the context in there
and then uh while you still have things
in the request stream because the one
that initially is the communication
channel is the client so you'll have to
see while I have something to read from
I'm going to also write what I can
receive so that's the
the biggest logic in here you can accept
access the current uh
message from the grpc channel by using
request stream dot current so that will
give you
um the type that is sent in uh request
usually
okay let's see how that looks like so we
have the server listening and then we
have the bi-directional one
which is going to do the same dot net
run
yeah so what I want you to see is that
it's sending an eye going to this value
and then um the server says okay I'm
gonna I received this and send basically
the value back uh one thing I'm going to
run it again with the no build this time
since save some time
I'm gonna run it again until I get a
scrambled uh kind of looking yeah
finally
you you'll see here that it's it looks
like it's not in order
yeah but in fact the order is guaranteed
once you're sending uh data the data
received on the server side is
guaranteed yeah so it's not uh scrambled
around so as you can see here it's still
in order sending seven then sending
eight then sending nine yeah and on the
server side server said it receives zero
then one then two and three and stuff
like that so they're not saying like
Okay I received the first one and then
the seventh one and stuff like that it's
it's in order even though the order is
kind of
combined okay
what else I need to show you here if you
have questions
I'm here
um
one thing
getting back to the internals of grpc
there are a few things
that they brag about and they that you
need to know for example in grpc the
status codes
are not the status codes that we know
and that might be like confusing when it
comes to uh grpc you will have like 16
status codes specific to the grpc
request itself and then on top of that
you have the HTTP ones that we all know
like 404 401 403 that we all use with
web API yeah another thing is
um
everything related to data validation
and uh
bad things happening in grpc it's an
exception you'll throw exceptions every
time a thing that doesn't work as
expected yeah so you'll have to filter
that
if you have a specific need for example
I should be in here
one of them
in here yeah so on the bi-directional
one you'll see that I am using a try
cats block and say hey in case of an RPC
exception
do something but now we have the option
of just filtering if the status code is
canceled write this
so you can do that for every other
things that you need for example if the
data that you're sending is not valid
throw an exception and catch it on the
client side one thing is that once
you're putting in production you'll have
to map the status codes
with messages that you add to a
middleware maybe to create like a
generic way of treating exception in
writing error codes
okay another thing that word needs to be
mentioned is that you can cancel
requests you can specify for example for
each
a call that hey if I do not get a
response back in this amount of time
kill it so treat it as okay I do not
care anymore it takes too much time
also you can't pour call to send a
cancellation token so if something takes
too much you can like always forget
about it
and this is a
for every method that you can Define in
there
another thing besides
um
RPC extra exceptions
it's going to display yeah
um is around interceptors you'll have an
additional way of injecting yourself in
the request pipeline besides middlewares
you can intercept and write code to
intercept what uh the calls Port type
you can intercept unary calls on the
consuming part you can do logging and
add authorization details in there and
then you can intercept the server side
just right before the the method is
executed so you can add a read in there
like headers or add other headers and
stuff like that so that will be run
after the middleware run so it's somehow
at a lower level than um the framework
middlewares
okay request headers it will be still
request headers at the protocol level
response headers the same but you'll
have an additional
um
way of sending metadata called response
trailers this can be attached under the
formal key of key value pairs
like this
these are simply you can add them from
the server implementation you can also
read them there
if needed
okay
let me minimize this
like this
so you'll have like this type this is
the type that they decided to use
metadata and a metadata entry you add
the key and you add a value and then
just simply write into the context
response trailer and add this key value
right and on the client side the
consuming party
where is it here yeah see we found some
trailer values in the grpc response this
is the
the header that I added and I checked if
those are there or not
okay
there are other things that you can
tweak for the any grpc request for
example you can specify uh that the
maximum message size is an amount that
is suitable for you
there is a a guideline somehow that no
message size should be more than one
megabyte
because otherwise you'll see performance
penalties so it's not intended for you
to transfer gigabytes of data over grpc
messages yeah there are other
Technologies for that but you can chunk
that gigabyte into one megabyte pieces
and send over the the network
um maximum send message size the same it
can be configured then you can configure
for example compression level
the compression algorithm and to specify
your own compression provider if you
want and of course you can add the type
of interceptors that um
you need here
security wise uh whatever your web API
supports grpc supports it too but you
will have two options you will have it
at the channel level so at the HTTP
level and then you can have something at
a more granular one or over the single
TCP call yeah so you have HTTP and then
grpc called inside it
uh it supports azer Eddie you can have
client certificates identity server jvt
I should remove the token from there or
oauth open ID connect everything that is
um is available pretty much and it
covers a lot of scenarios
what grpc should do awesome besides this
so besides this grpc transcoding so
basically it will allow you to have an
internal grpc service exposing the
browser without any additional tools the
thing with that is that yet is not so
stable so if you combine it with any
other things around the your jrpc
service it might act out and not work
as I found out found out with my
workshop okay
so just a sec in here
yeah so you will have like this is the
address of the server and then you can
configure like the endpoint you wanted
it to run
come on Zoom help me out a bit
yeah so I said that I wanted to be
exposed under V1 greeter and the name is
the the parameter yeah so if I add here
instead of name I don't know Madrid
it will be display
whoops whoops
I need to run this the Box start new
instance
yeah hello Madrid
uh how I added this wonderful feature is
just by simply installing a nugget
package related to transcoding
so in here it's called Microsoft
asp.core grpc transcoding they couldn't
have made this more longer
yeah add a few more segments
and
you just have it in here so this is the
RPC say hello returns reply that we've
seen before but this time we have the
option of exposing it as a get request
under this specific endpoint yeah you
can also do that you can also do a post
you can also do a put a delete just by
adding it in here
um the thing is whatever name you're
specifying in here
like to be bound from the endpoint
itself it will need to be present in the
hello request input in here
yeah so if you add here another name ID
or ID or something like that that it's
not
um
in the type you see this is the name
that I'm gonna be bound under here
I'm waiting for it to be disappeared so
to disappear I try
come on
okay so Zoom it doesn't want to behave
this morning
yeah so it needs to have a
okay yay it worked so the name is also
present in the field of the hello
request which hello request is the input
of our method yeah so it will have to be
uh there there's the cat though it's not
that easy just install a package and it
will work by itself the catch is is that
you will need by hand to paste a few
things and those few things are
this
I think they haven't yet invested in the
tooling and we have to do manual work if
we have this specific scenario for
example we need to have the Google
folder inside it we need to have an API
folder and inside the API folder we need
to have two protocol files these are
basically the ones that help with
transcoding yeah the thing is you'll
have to do it just once and then you're
going to copy the whole structure in
your project
uh yet I hope that they will improve
this
and another thing is that in your
gritter
uh file you'll have to import it so this
is how import work this is how you add
other files to your current file and
stuff like that it's just an import
directive pointing to the specific
specific folder in the the current
project
okay another thing that's supposed to be
uh nice about grpc and it's actually
nice but I'm not seeing it having a real
applicability
it's client-side load balancing and let
me show you something
done with the transcoding
and have this extras so
I'm going to start with retry policy
first because that's even nice so you
can specify a retry policy out of the
box say I'm gonna have a maximum tense
of two initial back off maximum back off
and the retrievable status code for me
are this like unavailable and deadline
exceeded you can have many of them in
there so what you're going to do is just
to pass this retry policy when you
create the channel yeah so we're gonna
uh pass the retry policy as the channel
options here
I'm going to do it here
because I didn't prepare it yet
so
method configs
I'm going to open another project that
already has it yeah
so you can specify either
um hedging policy or your tripology and
it will simply work the thing is you
won't be able to see it from the outside
because the retry is internal so you
won't see anything logged in
around it but you won't have like to
install a poly or something like that it
will have itself like in in grpc library
I think that I think will be the last
thing that I'm going to show you today
it's around a client-side load balancing
this is the thing that I told you I'm
not
seeing it as having a real applicability
with client-side load balancing you're
basically moving the awareness of
where what are the servers on the client
yeah so I don't think that the clients
would be aware whether his options but
okay I can connect there I can connect
there
when the load balancing policies the
load balancing concepts are supposed to
be transparent okay you're going to
connect and you're going to be served
from somewhere do you care from where as
long as you get a response back
um no you shouldn't care yeah but in
here we can configure for example a
static resolver Factory we're going to
say hey I know that I will have an
instance of the server running on this
address
and another instance of my server
running on this address yeah so I'm
gonna
this is what you'll have to do if you
have console apps like me if you have an
MVC or a web API or something else you
won't have to do the all the wiring
okay you're gonna say that I have a
single term resolver Factor this is my
Factory and then when you create the
channel you have to say that hey
um
I have this balancing config I want you
to to use the round robin config you
also can use the pick first but that
wouldn't be like your load balancing you
always gonna pick the first server in
there
and then uh just pass it in the factor
build a service provider that you just
uh
created in here yeah so what's going to
happen is whenever you create a client
with the channel that has all the
options
it will know to connect to the server on
to the second server and to the third
server that you have in something like
that so let's see we have a server
instance running
and then we should have a second service
we should have
is a keyword
okay I'm gonna
um this I'm gonna have the same server
running but under this um
this URL
so five thousand and five thousand and
two
because I need to pass it
no build
I pass it Noble While You're Building
okay
just a sec I'm gonna clear this out
I stopped Visual Studio because it's
either you run it from the console
or you end the double quotes indeed
what do you want
what is it's locked
I remove no build but it should have
worked without it
apparently I didn't pray to the demo
goes too much
and now it works ah
okay
fingers crossed
no
field please
okay so it's listening on this we have
the the first one to make run
so
run no build because this is the default
okay yay we have two several instances
this port and this one so listening and
what I'm gonna do is run the awesome
app that knows about these two servers
with the same options.net
run
no build
because otherwise I do not know what's
gonna happen
okay yay and it said that hello back
with Oslo value from localhost this port
and if I run it again hopefully
in one of the times
it should be the other Port around
which is this
yeah so we know how to balance it
himself which is rather nice
okay
so this is what uh supposed to to do
good
okay
what are the benefits and I'm gonna wrap
it up so benefits would be around
performance size and the data that
you're transferring over the network I
did some tests and if you also
compressed compress the the response
you'll end up like only one-fourth of
the entire message you would have with
web API it's good for polyglot
environments but as we've seen we we
don't even have that in real life
it will have low Network usage because
this the small payload it's awesome for
point-to-point communication and it's
awesome if you're using http apis
on your Downstream apis so you might
have have a look at maybe you can try to
to switch it to grpc in one of the cases
it uses uh HTTP to multiplexing under
the hood which is nice it's contract
based
supports different streaming types over
the single TCP connection and it's
already it can be configured with HTTP
3. yeah so I don't know about you but um
I just got my hand around the HTTP 2 and
now they're talking about the next
version HTTP 3. so it's hard to keep up
to be fair
um it will still have a temporal copying
so you'll still need the server to be up
in order to be served from it
um you might forget that there is
Network involved and you might abuse the
calls it's humor readable now because
Postman it has a version of
it allows you to do grpc requests
directly from that you need better
testing and you need to treat the the
status codes that you receive an
exceptions it will have no more caching
so if you want caching you might have a
look at the middle layer that caches
your data stuff like that which might
add the next or complexity in your
system
okay you'll have a single point of Truth
which is in a way it's good you have the
protophile that will be the the truth
for everything
so when and why do you RPC
there are specific cases but if you
currently have like a web API responding
to another web API you might give this a
try to see how it goes and maybe it will
benefit your system yeah so I truly
believe that when it comes to
distributed systems everything is about
trade-offs so you won't have like a
silver bullet to fix everything around
your system but we really need to know
the tools that we have at our hand to be
able to make informed decision when it
comes to our evolving the architecture
or simply just writing a simple API
being at a grpc or web API itself next
steps would be to have for you to have a
look at these things it might be it
might appear on your radar in the next
few
years maybe
and you have these two books that may be
worth having a look Mark Randall wrote
one of them if you have WCF it might
also be a good fit to try grpc instead
and thanks for listening thank you for
being here you have the resources in
here